voodoo
ミヤ王ねーっ
私先日め子を見かけたときにこの猫には締め切りって概念があるんだろうかとふと思い
ました
でその猫を見かけた後に街角で猫を見るたびにこの猫には閉め系あるかな
いやこの子はどうかなと
いうふうに猫を見るたびに締め切りのことを考えていました
あまり皆さん猫が締め切り持っているかどうかなんて考えたことないですよね
なぜ私がこういうことを考えているかと言うと私は大学
サイバー大学というところと東京情報大学という2つの大学でプロジェクト
マネージメントと
プロジェクトを管理するにはどうしたらいいかということを教えています
それだけじゃなくて企業に入って新商品の開発であるとかいろんなビジネスの立ち上げ
あるいは地域でのプロジェクトをどう立ち上げていくかどう運営していくかということ
を一緒に考えていく
そういう仕事をしています
プロジェクトというのは必ずゴールがあります
最終的なゴールがあるんですけどもそのゴールに至るまでに
例えば途中の段階までに品質はどこまで行っていたらいいのか
あるいは技術というのはどこにどこの日までに締め切りを守ったらいいのか
そしてコストというのは締め切りの日までにどこまでやればいいのか
最終的なゴールに行く前に途中途中で必ず締め切りがあります
ですから私はいつも締め切りのことを考えているんです
ビスから先ほどのように猫を見てもこの子は締め切りあるかなというふうに考えて
しまうわけです
私のみた結果猫に締切はありませんでした
どちらかというと動いたものを叩く
お腹が減ったら食べる
皆さんもご存知のように賢いので学習効果があります
でもいつまでに何後何かをしなきゃということで
true 度リストを作ってみたりとかできなかったねって後悔したりそういうことは
どうもないようです
締め切りについて今日は皆さんとお話をしたいんですけども
じゃあこの締め切りっていつから私達って認識できるようになったのでしょう
私がエジプト行った時にこのプロジェクトすごいですよね
ものすごい大きな建物建築建造物
でこのこういったプロジェクトを成し遂げるのにプロジェクトを管理する技能がなくて
は絶対できなかっただろうというふうに専門家としては感じたわけです
そういうことを感じて普段疑問を持っていろんな同僚の学者の先生とか
エジプト考古学の先生とかお話をしているとある
エジプト考古学の先生から皆さんご覧になっている
資料を見せていただきました
これはパピルスという神にヒーローグリフという象形文字で書かれたものです
これは抱えたのがちょうど先ほどご紹介したピラミッドができた中王国時代
紀元前2500年
ですから今からすると約4500年前ですね
ずっとずっと昔
その時に作られた文書ですアブシール文書と言います
アブシールというのは発掘された場所の名前です
これ何書いてあるかわかる人
よかった一人もいなかったですね
方に吹かれているのは
懸命ておりますけれども懸命というのは新しい神殿今度新しいなんとかっていう新聞を
作りますよ
そのために今ある供給地ておりますけれどもどこそこ3乾パンを運んで来てくださいと
いうリストです
でここに5種類のパンが書いてあるんですね何何パン何何番街枚
も種類のパンがあって
縦に日付が並んでます
1日から縦に日付が並んでいてそして3つずつのカラム目並んでいるんですけども
予定実績歳という風に書いてありません
1日にこのパンを3つ持ってきてください
で実績3つ持ってきたら債は0
1日2日目の日にパンを2個持ってきてください
持って来なかったら妻はにリコ持って来なかったです
この表を見たときに私はびっくりしました
私たちがいつもエクセルで作っている実績管理
あるいはその売り上げの4実績予算を立てて実績を積み上げていく
できなかったねできたねという話をしているのはちょうどいい右側に書いてありますよ
エクセルで私たち強く作りますよね
こういう表を作ったことがあるかと
結構いますねやはり針
こういう私たちが今日常で行なっている
excel 使っている予算管理締め切りを
1日前だったら1日に持っていくという締機をやるという方法はもう
4500年前からやっていて
あまりこの締め切りをどうやって守っていくかという技術自体は語られていません
締め切りまでに必ず届ける届けなかったら怒られる
これぐらいです
私はサイバー大学というインターネットの大学で授業を持っているんですけども私の
授業
プロジェクトマネジメント入門というクラスで
山楽器
これは300人いるクラスです
で事業というのは15日間の間に受講すれば出席
でそれ以降に受けると遅刻あるいは受けなかったということになるんですね
このグラフは1回目から12回目までをプロットしたものです
ですから12本本が線があります
人間の傾向って恐ろしいですよねもう明らかに見て同じような傾向線をたどる12回
最初のあたりに開校してすぐ初日に受ける人こういう人は毎回一緒です
だいたい11人から10人くらい受けてそしてまあまあ同じような人数がずーっと言っ
て
皆さんも経験があるように締め切りの前の日
あの米14てか中4日目が一番ドーンと会マーク
ましたが締め切りだから共演なきゃっていうんで頑張る
そして最後の日にもう本当にバタバタですね
最後のあと何時間という時に提出をして悪
でおしまいです
でこの暮らすというのは300人いるクラスなんですけども
だいたい期限内に受けてくれるか学生が260人くらい
平均して推移していました
私は教員としてこの260人
42遅れているわけですからここをなんとかして減らしたい
もっとこの期限内に受ける学生を増やしたいと思いまして
この線学期秋学期ですから正月の期間年末年始の期間は1週間延ばしてあげたんです
締め切りを
するとどうなったか
皆さん
締め切りが1週間のいました
いつ頃やりますか
そうですね
予想通り
1週間ずれただけです
2回だけずらしてあげて伸ばしてあげたんですけども見事に後ろにグラフがずれたっ
最初から受ける人はも受けるんですけども後ろにずれていっ
これはスチューデントシンドロームっています学生症候群
締め切りを伸ばしてもその締め切りに合わせて後ろに山がずれるだけですよ
これをもう1週間延ばしても同じ現象が起きます
私がプロジェクト管理の専門家ですけれども失敗したのは恐ろしいことに262たのが
総数252ヘッダんです
逆に増えると思ったのがモチベーションが逆に下がってしまって
ヘッダーこれはもう大失敗なんですね学生からもいるいろいろ言われました
この結果を見せた時に
先生
専門家なのに the してるじゃんずらしておかげで減らしているよねっていうこと
でえええ
指摘を受けたんですけれどもそういうふうに締め切りをどうするかっていうのは
ものすごい難しいです
でも私たちは一条の生活の中で締め切りと付き合っていかなきゃいけば仕事も生活も
できません
後ろに写ってるのは私がもう十数年使っている手帳です
毎回同じ手帳を使っているんですけれどもですからもう10集札
本棚に残っています
必ず実行していることがあります
まあよく to do と言いますけれどもやらなければいけないことを書いて
その前に資格魯能字を書きます
で終わったらチェックを吸う
チェックをしてそれを眺めるあまり眺める人いないかもしれないです私は必ず眺め
で終わったあと1週間振り返ってみて塗りつぶしがないかどうかを確認する
でまた久しぶりに見たときに先月の分はどうだろうと思って振っめくって new
乗りつぶしがないかどうか確認するこれで安心するわけです
もし戸ノ内が開いたままになっているともう不安で不安でしょうがないんでやっぱりム
クっておきてそれを消しにかかります
でこのことをズンズンズンズンやり続ける
これがもう習慣になっています
これは何にいいかといいますと
締め切りを達成する
そうすると達成感をやった
私のその17年の手帳で論じにチェックをしてない項目は一個もありません
全部潰しています
あまり難しい方は小さな簡単な課題にしたり
これはどうしても無理だなと思った消しちゃったり消すの消しゴムで消すんじゃなくて
線を引いてきです
でずっと見返すと
そうすると自分の脳内ホルモンドーパミン店を出てきます
そして快感を得る
このドーパミンのいいところはお金を出さなくても自分で発生できるんですね
自分に発生して自分で快感を得るこれを繰り返していくと自分がハッピーな気分になる
これはもう本当にお手軽な方法です
これをずっとずっと繰り返す
チェックして眺めて快感を得
そうすると友達締め切りと友達になれる
この締め切りという友達すごく付き合うのに厄介なものです
追っかけられると私たちはすごいプレッシャーを感じますよね
逆にいいのは追っかける
自分から締め切りを追っかけて行くととても良い友達になります
先ほど行ったみたいに快感を得る
0締め切りをかけていく
こういうふうに締め切りを友達にする
締め切りを
追いかけろ
ありがとうございました
th
b